[Musique]
bonjour bonjour Éric orsena merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous l'académicien
Éric orsena merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation Éric orsena vous êtes un
fidèle du Congrès des mères qui s'est
tenu cette semaine et vous avez parcouru
les allées du Congrès comme chaque année
dans quel état d'esprit vous avez trouvé
ma et bien ils sont euh toujours
déterminés c'est ça qui me fascine c'est
cette générosité quotidienne moi j'ai
des générosités par impulsion par des
missions eux c'est jour après jour et la
nuit aussi et quel que soit petite ville
grande ville ils sont tous là et puis
ils s'interrogent parce que quand même
ils se font agresser en plus ils ont des
questions difficiles à régler h quand
même notamment des questions climatiques
moi mon métier c'est l'eau temps en
temps c'est la sécheresse temps en temps
c'est l'inondation et puis et puis il
voit la suite donc ça va donner et puis
ils ont plus les moyens et puis ils sont
perdus ils sont perdus parce qu'ils
savent pas qui fait quoi donc c'est vrai
que la mission que le Président de la
République a confié à Ric vert est une
bonne mission sur la décentralisation on
va revir là-dessus mais c'est vrai qu'on
a on a beaucoup parlé de la lassitude
des mes du découragement vous c'est
c'est pas le premier mot qui
si des gens si des gens sont pas
découragés c'est eux parce que le
courage c'est pas à un moment donné on
abandonne mais ils sont là encore vous
savez moi je passe le tiers de mon temps
à Paris et les deux autres tiers dans un
petit village en côte d'Armor et dans un
petit village à la frontière entre leur
aloir et les ivelines et les deux mères
Lydia en coup d'armort et Philippe là
sont des amis intimes parce que je vois
jour après jour ce qu'ils font dans tous
les domaines l'économique le social
l'éducation l'environnement travaille
avec les différentes formes de de
d'agriculture comme en parlait monsieur
le sénateur donc je vois on est dans le
concret pourquoi j'aime les m pour une
raison très simple j'aime de de passion
mon pays et bien quand on aime son pays
on aime les me vous qui les voyez chaque
année est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que leur état d'esprit a évolué alors
l'état d'esprit est plus est plus clair
ils veulent des on leur a tellement dit
des choses que vous comprenez même les
mots quand ils dépendent non plus d'une
taxe c'est-à-dire que c'est quelque
chose qui voilà qui est peu général dans
le budget de l'État mais d'une dotation
c'est de l'omô ils dépendent du bon
vouloir c'est pas possible comprenez ça
un moment donné il faut les actes on dit
que la décentralisation il faut mettre
de l'ordre on met de l'ordre mais il va
falloir bien se rendre compte de ce que
ça veut dire moi je vais vous vais vous
dire euh sur les questions d'eau qui est
donc mon métier euh je me suis rendu
compte de l'importance des
départements parce que j'y croyais pas
moi je disais trop de strat trop de
millefeuilles tout ça allez hop on vire
les départements bien je vais vous
rendez je vais vous donner mon mon
expérience sur la gestion de l'eau
regardez vous avez les Deux Sèvres bien
c'est pas du tout la même chose que la
vendz les deux Sèv il y a saints Soline
où personne n d'accord alors qu'en
vendez tout le monde une grande
tradition est de se mettre d'accord et
il y a énormément de réserves je dis
jamais bassine quand vous dites bassine
je suis académicien donc un peu des mot
les M un sens vous êtes mort c'est une
réserve et bien on vendz il y a plein de
réserves et les gens sont en accord
alors que dans le département voisins
donc quelle est la bonne échelle
d'action moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse
voyez donc pour vous il faut pas
supprimer le strat parce que c'est un
débat qu'on a entendu à l'Assemblée des
départements de franceé d'avis et moi je
pense que là sur ces questionsl le
département pour moi existe à l'inverse
c'est une autre question qui m'intéresse
beaucoup c'est les communes les interc
et les aglos parce que les maires savent
plus où ils sont ils savent plus où ils
sont financièrement on en a dit un mot
mais ils savent plus savoir quelle est
la responsabilité donc moi je vois chez
moi donc bah dans mon petit village où
sais tout est à l'anion comment ça se
passe avec l'agion comment ça marche on
sait plus quoi et donc quand on sait
plus qui c'est c'est l'irresponsabilité
et l'impuissance de ces gens si généreux
combien ils gagnent les maires vous
rendez compte ce que ça veut dire jour
encore une fois jour après jour ouais
une grande partie des indemnités qui
sont inférieures au SMIC on va revenir
sur la question des indemnités puisque
vous parlez finalement d'une forme de
simplification qu'il faudrait opérer
Emmanuel Macron à l'élyisée il a parlé
d'un système C par-dessus tête c'est
c'est le mot que vous emploirez aussi
oui si vous voulez moi à propos du
président de la République que ça soit
Emmanuel Macron ou d'autres euh je pense
qu'il faudra une règle que avec laquelle
personne sera d'accord mais moi c'est
mon
irresponsabilité est-ce qu'on peut être
président de la République sans avoir
été élu précédemment et ben je pense que
non de la même manière que je suis mais
fermement opposé maintenant à
l'interdiction de cumul des mandats
quand on dit regardez le mot cumulle
c'est C par-dessus Têtre aussi cumule
cumule on dit cumule cumul et bien
cumular c'est quoi c'est l'expérience
être
législateur c'est pas un métier comme un
autre on n'est pas comptable il faut une
expérience comprenez c'est ça j'ai été
25 ans conseiller d'État donc je sais ce
que c'est que des des des textes de loi
bah ça vient pas comme ça donc c'est une
expérience on met un peu d'ordre
là-dedans mais il se trouve que moi je
le connais pas mais j'ai de respect pour
tout ce qu'il a fait donc j'attends de
Eric vert qui a cette grande expérience
là qui qui il a de la mesure et
l'expérience donc on va voir ça va
donner mais ouais juste sur Emmanuel
Macron parce que c'est c'est de lui dont
vous parlez le président qui n'a pas été
élu local est-ce que au bout de 6 ans il
les comprend les maires ou toujours pas
vous écoutez j'ai pas eu évidemment ces
très très hautes fonctions mais j'ai été
conseiller culturel de François bterant
bien quand vous venez de
l'Élysée je j'allais en France tout le
temps on vous parle pas de la même
manière c'est pas pareil donc j'étais de
fait à côté de Jacques Lang Son
vice-ministre on parle pas de la même
manière mais quand vous êtes en élu élu
et obligé de de décider jour après jour
et de de garder un cap au milieu des
contradictions ça rien à voir que d'être
là et très franchement il reçoit les
mares chez lui il va pas chez eux moi
j'ai été blessé pour eux que il n'aille
pas au salon on va au salon de
l'agriculture et on va pas au salon des
mèr c'est quoi ça un manque de respect
considération écoutez tout doit se
passer là bah c'est pas vrai voyez moi
c'est cette vision là donc il a un
dynamisme que j'admire il a tout ça et
ca mais cette ce ce lien ce lien vital
avec la France moi j'ai vu beaucoup de
présidents parce que des liens très
forts avec évidemment François midran
mais aussi Jacques Chirac avec d'autres
comme ça qui était là euh la la France
c'est c'est même même si vous allez
partout de haut c'est moins que d'aller
dans quelques endroits du bas ouais et
ça restera une trace dans ces mandats
euh le fait de ne pas avoir été euh on
verra moi je m'inqu je m'inquiète de la
suite mais vous savez bah parce que on
va voir un peu ce qui va se passer
c'est-à-dire que euh le le le le pays il
faut il faut être parmi eux vous savez
il faut être regarder moi moi je je
reviens de de de ce qui en ce moment je
travaille sur l'agriculture et la fin
avec Julien Normandie et
j'étais dans la justement dans la
banlieu de Nancy dont vous parliez dans
des endroits complètement perdus et je
voyais le travail d' tél caronde voir ce
que c'est quand vous imaginez quand même
que 16 % des Français ne mangent pas à
leur fa 16 % des Français alors
évidemment dans mon milieu académicien
ancien conseiller d'État on sait pas ça
veut dire faut aller les voir mais pas
aller les voir en disant je vais vous
apporter le truc et aller avec eux
partager un peu ce qui se passe c'est
pour ça voyez que moi j'avais pas cette
générosité quotidienne c'est pour ça
j'ai toujours refusé de de de tenter une
élection ou d'être ministre mais parce
que c'est c'est c'est je me dis bon ils
sont élus moi je suis lu mais pour être
lu il faut que je sois avec eux que je
partage vous savez un écrivain celui qui
vit la vie des
autres l'enquête du il y a une enquête
du cvipov qui a été réalisée auprès de
milliers de ma mais que vous auriez très
bien pu remonter vous aussi qui met en
exerc ce besoin de reconnaissance qu'on
les élu aujourd'hui comment on y répond
vous savez euh j'aime beaucoup ce mot
reconnaissance parce que il y a
connaissance et reux vois on dit en
Afrique vous savez tout le monde peut
venir tout commence quand on revient et
quand vous apprenez la botanique ce qui
a été mon cas parce que j'y connaissais
rien on allait dans ce qu'on appelle des
travaux de reconnaissance c'est a deux
sens sa reconnaissance reconnaissance ça
veut dire distinguer les plantes les
unes des autres et en même temps ça veut
dire merci et moi le premier mot que
j'ai appris c'est grâce à ma mère c'est
merci pour une raison très simple c'est
quand je disais pas merci elle disait
j'entends pas et comme j'adorais ma mère
je voulais qu'elle entende je disais
merci merci merci donc reconnaissance ça
veut dire leur dire merci savoir qui
sont donc les aider à déterminer leurs
tâches et leurs responsabilités et en
même temps leur dire merci euh est-ce
qu'on leur dit suffisamment merci un les
politiques et deux aussi peut-être les
citoyens parce que dans l'enquête du
cvipof la la la PR première le premier
sujet d'inquiétude et et de malêtre des
mes c'est une trop grande attente de
leurs concitoyens mais comme c'est
l'incarnation de de de je sais pas de de
de ce qu'on veut de de d'un pouvoir
central le pouvoir total c'est quasiment
divin donc si ça marche pas c'est de ta
faute et c'est violent c'est de ta faute
ils disent ça c'est de ta faute c'est à
toi et dans tous les domaines les plus
divers j'ai pas d'emploi c'est ta faute
et cetera donc il y a il y a pas que la
responsabilité des politiques il y a
aussi la responsabilité des citoyens
c'està-dire qu'est-ce que c'est la
République c'est une œuvre commune c'est
pas ça vient pas d'en haut et cetera et
notamment le respect du travail moi je
suis dans ce qu'on appelle voilà la
socialdémocratie c'està-dire on est plus
que 2 ou 3 % en France mais j'assume
comme ça je continue il y a quand même
avant avant de distribuer il faut
produire et bien comment on produit par
le travail et il se trouve que j'aime le
travail moi si vous voyez mes premier
manuscrit c'est épouvantable alors que
j'ai écrit 70 livres et après petit à
petit et c'est pour ça que je me sens un
peu comme les agriculteurs parce que on
se lève au même moment c'està-dire je
les vois on prend le café comme ça vers
11h moi j'ai essayé de faire pousser des
phrases à partir de ma de ma de ma
feuille blanche et eux dans les chambes
vous en avez un peu parlé RIC orena les
violences envers les élus augmente plus
32 % l'année dernière plus 15 % cette
année selon les prévisions de
l'Association des mères de France
qu'est-ce que ça dit de la France et de
la République d'aujourd'hui c'est ça
veut dire que l'individualisme est là
maximum tout pour ma gueule et donc je
fais pas l'effort moi mais c'est
toujours quelqu'un d'autre qui est
responsable toujours le Bou émissaire
alors le Bou émissaire comme on a dit
apporté jeif sber toujours à côté et si
on se demandait qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
moi vous savez c'était c'était Kennedy
c'était tout le monde qui disait un peu
tu demandes ce que le pays a fait pour
toi est-ce que tu ASIT qu'est-ce que tu
as fait sur le pays c'est un peu ça ça
ce qui se passe quand même il y a une
sorte de de d'examen de conscience qui
doit être fait de chacun de la même
manière que pour le climat mais on
trouve assez normal de dire qu'est-ce
que tu fais pour le climat toi avec les
nutriscor les machins et cetera mais on
dit pas qu'est-ce que tu fais pour le
pays tu as fait quoi pour le pays toi
derniers temps pour l'ensemble parce que
cette belle chose s'appelle la
République qu'est-ce que tu as fait rien
fait tu as attendu il y a il y a des on
a des droit mais d'abord il y a des
devoirs s'il y a pas de devoirs il y a
pas de droit il y a une quarantaine de
maères qui démissionnent par mois de
depuis le depuis 2020 depuis le début de
leur mandat c'est ce que dit David lisna
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes inquiet
pour la démocratie bien sûr je suis
inquiet pour la démocratie bien sûr vous
savez regardez ce que se disent les mots
vous voyez à chaque fois je c'est chacun
son métier mais démission c'est-à-dire
on abandonne sa mission démissions ça
veut bien dire c'était une mission c'est
pas un métier c'est pas une ambition
c'est une mission et qui sort de cette
mission quelle plus belle mission c'est
comme quand on voit que des médecins
comme on dit déplaquent arrête d'être
médecin ou il essayent de trouver
d'autres choses bah voilà ça ça veut
dire qu'on sort de sa mission quelle
plus belle mission que prendre soin bah
c'est des sortes de c'est c'est des
c'est des médecin de notre pays à chaque
fois qu'il y a une crise qui on va voir
quand il y a eu une là dernièrement il y
a eu cette terrible tempête en Bretagne
qui était au premier rang bah c'était
les services publics et les maires mais
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une
crise démocratique pour vous oui bien
sûr que oui on est une crise
démocratique voilà il faut vous savez la
démocratie c'est comme l'amour hein
c'est dire la démocratie il faut la
réinventer sans arrêt si on considère
que c'est gagné on est mort donc avec et
avec des grandes tentations de régime
fort puisqu'on doit faire beaucoup de
transition notamment à cause de toutes
ces voilà ces agression du climat on
voit bien et ben il faut se dire comment
est-ce qu'on va faire parce que la
tentation est grande de dire comme on n
arrive pas en démocratie parce que c'est
tout pour ma gueule et ben on va prendre
un régime fort c'est-à-dire lui il va
imposer alors même que il y a en Chine
qui est la grande voilà on regarder on
décide on décide et ben ça marche pas
quand il y a pas de démocratie régime
fort ce serait qui chez nous bah les
régimes fort on voit bien les tendances
c'est-à-dire vous savez j'ai j'ai fait
une erreur
euh avec quelques-uns en disant
l'alternance ça va pas on va mettre les
meilleurs ensemble le en même temps et
bien les meilleurs ensembles c'est la
prime aux extrême et moi je suis revenu
à l'alternance on a besoin de droite on
a besoin de gauche quand on respire on
respire pas en même temps on inspire on
expire c'est ça le le souffle de la
République donc ça veut dire que la fin
du cvage gauche- droite théorisé par
Emmanuel Macron ça a fait le jeu
notamment de Marine Le Pen et et et de
la nu et jeanluc Mélenchon et de la côté
regardez un peu ce qui se passe
c'est-à-dire étrangement le en même
temps divise l'alternance rassemble on
va parler de l'eau puisque évidemment
c'est c'est votre grand sujet orsena
cette question de l'eau l'an passé on
parlait beaucoup de sécheresse on en a
parlé d'ailleurs quand vous étiez venu
cette année c'est plutôt que d'eau que
d'eau alors c'est ça la question c'est
que il y a la même quantité d'eau c'est
ça ce qu'il faut savoir c'est a la même
quantité d'eau le grand cyle tout ça
etation et cetera simplement elle elle
elle coule pas de façon tempérée
régulière et on a l'alternance des
phénomènes extrêmes parce que c'est
c'est le le le la la conséquence du
dérèglement climatique avec
l'augmentation des des des températures
et étrangement vous avez moins d'eau
disponible quand il y a une qu' il y en
a une sécheresse parce que l'inondation
va un peu partout on a vu les les
terribles les terribles événements dans
le nord de la France et quand j'ai été
au Congrès des mires j'ai dédicacé mon
livre la terre à soif c'était
passionnant il y avait 60 mes qui sont
venus et tous il me disait ah dans dans
ma commune dans les chartreuses voilà ce
qui s'est passé je suis prês
d'unkererque voilà ce que ça donne je
suis voyez donc c'était une
extraordinaire diversité et en même
temps la la sorte de de de confirmation
ce que j'ai toujours pensé l'eau c'est
le miroir mais pas pour voir sa gueule
c'est le miroir nos société dis-moi
comment tu gères l'eau privé publique à
quel prix pour qui au bénéfice de qui de
quelle action et cetera je te dirai
exactement à quel type de société tu
appartiens et on a discuté d'eau sans
arrêt alors ils étaient là ils
attendaient patiemment que je parle
d'eau avec chacun des maires et donc
avec ce BIA là c'est extraordinaire
parce qu'on est en plein dans le partage
reflète dans le miroir alors aujourd'hui
bah c'est la diversité moi quand on me
dit est-ce que tu es pour les réserves
ou pas ça dépend des endroits chez moi
en Bretagne il y a pas de NAP fréatique
donc il faut réserver les choses mais
c'est complètement idiot de laisser
filer comme ça l'eau on a bien vu le
manque le manque de de d'infrastructure
dans le Nord je travaille beaucoup avec
les canalisateurs c'est passionnant de
voir un peu ça avec des contradictions
parce que quand vous réhabilitez tél
réseau qui permet de d'économiser
souvent 20 ou 30 % parfois il y a des
associations de défense de
l'environnement qu'on peut comprendre
quand il y avait une fuite il y avait
une zone humide si vous réhabilitez il y
a plus de fuite mais est-ce qu'il faut
est-ce qu'il faut revoir aujourd'hui nos
manières de construire pour tenir compte
de ce risque de l'eau et et nos manières
d'entretenir également lesors on est
dans les contradictions aussi j'étais
hier avec la Fédération du Bâtiment vous
savez que c'est le prochain drame de
notre pays c'est le manque de logement
on est passé de de 40000 50000 Chac
année et ça diminue diminue comment
est-ce qu'on va loger les gens mais
comment en même temps on va
réindustrialiser s'il y a personne pour
loger et comment en même temps on va
pouvoir en même temps parce que là c'est
les contradiction de fait comment est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir loger plus en
protégeant mieux les territoires donc et
c'est ça qui est très intéressant de
voir à quelle échelle il faut décider
c'est pas Bercy qui doit décider seul
c'est région par région en accord avec
les agriculteurs parce qu'on on dit zéro
artificialisation des des
des des sols très bien mais où ça veut
dire quoi où et on peut très bien et en
plus on peut très bien construire en
respectant on peut très bien avoir des
parkings avec l'eau qui coule et cetera
donc le possible est là et on revient à
la décentralisation donc alors et on
revient à la décentralisation qui est
choisir la bonne échelle spatiale quelle
est quelle est la bonne échelle voyez
par exemple à l'échelle du bassin pour
l'eau mais c'est pareil aussi pour la
construction et puis et puis quelle est
la bonne échelle de temps c'est-à-dire
est-ce qu'on se donne un peu de temps ou
pas mais que ça soit clair il y a eu un
drame on a on a supprimé l'aménagement
du territoire on a supprimé le
commissariat à l'aménagement du
territoire qui moi me passionnait quand
j'étais petit quand j'étais à sciencep
gamin on a on a abandonné ça et on a cru
que all les forces du marcher all le
ruissellement ça marche pas les plus
riches sont encore plus riches et les
autres tout ça donc c'est ça cette
affaire la géographie est une volonté
pour terminer r Orsina puisque vous nous
avez beaucoup parlé de mots pendant cet
entretien on voudrait vous entendre sur
la question de la langue française vous
étiez à Viller côteray il y a quelques
semaines quand Emmanuel Macron a
inauguré cette Cité internationale de la
langue française le français Simon qui
bâtit l'unité de la nation a dit le chef
de l'État c'est encore vrai aujourd'hui
mais évidemment mais évidemment c'est et
que quand on a pas le sentiment de de la
langue commune c'est la violence qui
l'emporte donc le français évolue vous
ça fait le français est une langue
vivante j'ai fait un livre avec le
l'immense savant Bernard cerchilini sur
les mots immigrés et il faut savoir que
dans notre origine et ça fait pas de
plaisir à certains mais je m'en fous il
y a beaucoup plus de mots d'origine
arabe dans la langue française que de
mots d'origine gauloise donc il faut
qu'il sache cela avant d'invectiver il
faut quand même savoir et donc ce genre
de question donc maintenant la langue
comme ça doit doit doit doit vivre doit
vivre avec des vraies questions par
exemple la féminisation et pour moi des
mauvaises réponses avec des points
partout à la fin alors justement parce
que au moment où vous étiez à
villercotret le Sénat votait sur un
texte pour interdire l'écriture
inclusive pour vous l'écriture inclusive
c'est une évolution de la langue ou
c'est une dérive non c'est à mon sens
c'est c'est une vraie question une vraie
question la féminisation parce que qui a
le pouvoir des mots à le vrai pouvoir et
une inquiétude que j'ai très forte le
monde numérique c'est un monde de mec
les femmes côent pas c'est-à-dire que le
le l'hyper langage le méta langage qui
en train d'être créé ça sera un
métaangage de mec et donc cette question
elle est énorme donc si on revient à la
langue française je pense que pour être
pour mon sentiment c'est'est pas la
peine d'interdire ça va décliner tout
seul ce qu'on voit nous l'écriture
inclusive oui l'écriture inclusive ce
qu'on voit nous avec à l'Académie c'est
que l'important c'est l'usage il y a des
mots qui m'a marche très bien comme
ordinateur et d'autres qui étaient
pourtant magnifiqu comme baladeur qui
marche pas donc on voit un peu ce que ça
donne et puis faut surtout donner envie
de cette belle langue française donc
quand je vois la ministre de la Culture
qui lance ce grand rendez-vous de la
poésie et pour les jeunes il y a
beaucoup de poésie parce que c'est court
c'est bref ça touche voyez et donc et et
donc cette langue on l'aime tellement et
on on parle on parle ensemble c'est
voilà c'est c'est c'est si vous voulez
au fond on me dirait est-ce que tu es
français ou francophone quelque chose me
dit que je suis peut-être plus
francophone encore que français parce
que la France bon mais en plus comme
disait très bien Maurice Bron c'est une
langue en partage la France est bien
moins l'Académie française on n'est pas
propriétaire du français et je vais
faire mon marché linguistique en
Belgique en Suisse en Afrique au Québec
quand vous avez vu Gabriel Atal qui a
rendu public les évalu des élèves de 4e
notamment et que la moitié d'entre eux
ne savent pas lire correctement comment
on en est arrivé là aujourd'hui écoutez
franchement je sais pas mais ça c'est un
drame parce que c'est non seulement un
drame pour la nation mais un drame aussi
pour l'inégalité parce que quand vous
avez la chance de une famille qui pie
certaines insuffisances de l'éducation
nationale bien il y en a qui auront la
maîtrise et d'autres qui auront pas la
maîtrise et quand vous avez pas la
maîtrise de votre langue vous avez pas
la maîtrise du principal outil donc la
question de d'apprendre le français
comme les mathématiques et tout ça est
absolument central donc c'est tout se
joue tout se joue au primaire tout se
joue au primaire et la question de
l'éducation nationale c'est le chantier
de notre pays cet école qui a construit
l'unité de la République est en train de
favoriser l'inégalité et ça c'est
absolument impossible j'ai vu Gabriel
Atal et donc je suis absolument à la
disposition moi vous savez sur ma tombe
il y aura
prof j'ai été prof j'ai adoré apprendre
et j'essaie de transmettre prof donc
prof c'est la plus belle démission avec
les maires mais ce qui est un peu
paradoxal parce que toute la philosophie
de l'éducation nationale depuis quelques
années c'est de faire justement de
l'égalité voir de l'égalitarisme est-ce
que du coup ça a pas produit l'effet
inverse en favorisant les inégalités et
bien on est d'accord là-dessus et
regarde et quand vous voyez que une part
croissante des enfants de ceux qui ont
les moyens vont dans le privé ça c'est
très mauvaise nouvelle parce que c'est
comme on voit l'abandon de la maîtrise
de la dette là c'est l'abandon aussi
c'est une autre dette après la dette
financière la dette environnementale
c'est la dette inégalitaire mais cette
philosophie elle a conduit un
nivellement par le bas de l'éducation
nationale ça dépend il faut voir les
endroits c'est c'est encore une fois il
y a des écoles publiques magnifiques et
d'autres moins alors peut-être que voilà
il faut bien voir que bah il y en a qui
sont meilleurs que d'autres et puis il
faut réveiller ceux qui sont Mo bons
Gabriel Atal il premet un choc des
savoirs il va présenter un plan dans
quelques jours quel conseil vous lui
donnerez don d'abord extraordinairement
extraordinairement humble mais déterminé
comme toujours et avec la vraie question
est-ce que vous savez j'ai participé ici
même au Sénat qui était organisé par le
président Larcher et peut-on réformer
l'éducation nationale c'est son job bon
courage tout vieux petit prof que je
suis sera à ses côtés avec tout l'amour
que je peux avoir pour pour mon pays et
pour ma langue voilà il a peut-être
entendu le message merci Eric orsena
merci beaucoup pour cet entretien qui
était passionnant merci d'avoir été
notre invité on rappelle le titre de
votre livre il était une fois la terre
et vous avez un livre en préparation
avec Julien de Normandie et oui parce
que je suis passionné par l'agriculture
on m'a plusieurs fois proposé d'être
ministre de la Culture jamais de
l'agriculture alors je voulais lutter
contre cette jalousie et avec Julien on
essaie de voir l' contradiction par
exemple on on adore importer ce qu'on
s'interdit de produire et comme ça la
France la merveilleuse France si l'hiver
si riche si fertile importe la moitié de
ces fruits et légumes on marche sur la
tête comme dirait notre cher Président
le cul par-dessus tête vous viendrez
nous en parler c'est en février c'est ça
bien sûr comme vous avez remarqué je
suis d'un
bavardage mais c'est toujours un plaisir
on vous recevra à ce momentlà merci R